[Music]
so Bart I know you have said you didn't
get a chance to try to use breast milk
but I did it would you do it yeah I know
it's such a this next time around
talk [ __ ] with his hands you always say
that and I don't know what you're really
trying to say the fact that you
literally pick up dog [ __ ] with your
booty mean that you're [ __ ] crazy
that's what I'm trying to say but that's
a very creative person fine that's very
positive sometimes uses dog [ __ ] as
an example of things that are
interesting questions to ask so we all
know would try and breast milk Wilma
suck it I'm a summary no titty well chop
the top chocolate for its sweet did you
go from the titty that's what I heard
you're seeing convinced me no I did it
you go from the source yeah that sounds
better
is it warmer yeah it was warm it wasn't
good I mean why would it be called out
of a bottle I mean it might be lukewarm
or is it hot I didn't say cold you guys
put the cold I mean anything when women
have had a child before like even when
they're not breastfeeding I think
sometimes that is this still sometimes
produces so I feel like absurd not a
couple titties before that still had
some milk in it did you get full I
wasn't going for that it was more of
like a you know just like a fetish type
thing like sort that [ __ ] in your mama I
gave my mom a titty twister nipple
twister and a little bit of milk came
out really we were taking a bath
together you say wouldn't we're taking a
bath at 5:00 no in elementary school so
elementary school is like eight or nine
okay
culture and Japanese cool it's kind of
like um it's like you you it's like a
place where you gossip been talking
entity twist apparently your parents
it's cultural treaty twisting titties
wisdom is cultural for parents just
gonna just to make sure I love I'm
really gullible no I seriously if you
ever run a Japanese lady just [ __ ] to
you love it that's it that means hi how
are you bridge the cultural grab
immediately you're wishing her good
fortune just good fortune I was like
that's not attended to is that's the
[ __ ] finishing move well that's where
family's it's different yeah okay so the
story I have in front of me today well
you know why she did it first that's why
uh let's look at that got you guys a
[ __ ] it was revenge okay okay so the
reason why I bring up breast milk in our
lives because there's this article
that's talking about these Ugandan men
who demand breast milk I think it's
getting kind of great what do you mean
it's [ __ ] up [ __ ] up because what's
happening here is they're they're
forcing their girls to breast feed these
grown-ass men before their own child
gets to drink this milk and they'll be
breastfeeding for like a whole ass hour
well we gotta go work it because it's
magical so the thing is they're saying
that they feel like so okay for starters
this is not like this is this seems to
be like a common thing but like an like
an unspoken thing like no one's really
talking about it but it's being it's a
common practice it's a secret kinda so
so the researchers are trying to look
into this phenomenon here but because
it's not widely talked about it's kind
of hard to really study this so but what
they what they have found when they
interview some people that wanted to
remain anonymous like some guys said
that they this is one quote it says it
sustains me I come home from lunch and
it relieves stress in the middle of the
workday
another one said like he's like I know
other men do it but we never talk
so that to me would suggest that it's
coming behavior wasn't socially accepted
another one says that when breastfeeding
I feel like I'm being looked after like
a child and it becomes addictive I feel
like a prince so that's what's happening
they get hella addicted to breastfeeding
and now these women are like they're
getting beat if they say no wow oh and
then these children are at risk of like
also these women will come in with like
[ __ ] to help nipples cuz these men will
bite their nipples too so sometimes I'll
use it to like initiate sex but then it
gets a little crazy I guess and also
these kids like these babies are
supposed to be getting their nourishment
from the little bit no food well it's
not that they're not getting food is
that their they're being exposed to the
risk of infection and like germs and
[ __ ] yeah because other people saliva
yeah I'd like these men's saliva that
they should not be some kind of like
witch doctor [ __ ] going on like this is
magical you have not saying you better
not say tongue condoms excuse me are you
I thought you guys they ought to be
aware tongue course not are they wearing
diapers yeah no I don't know but some of
the funniest so have you seen Ugandan
news
no okay funny I don't even have that
channel dude it's like a meme like
people watch that [ __ ] on YouTube it
like like this is that one guy where
he's all like why are you dead Oh have
you seen that the Asian massage guy who
he gets chicks to lay down and then he
starts smelling her [ __ ] and like yeah
Eddie [ __ ] rubs their asses what like
it's like [ __ ] book really needs
their butts and [ __ ] that's that part
that feels really good
well it's also like pretty nuts cuz he
puts his nose right up to him he's doing
yoga they seated they think it's some
kind of a [ __ ] great thing I hate
this [ __ ] I
disgusting also saying like the reason
why they'll get violent too is because
sometimes these men come home drunk and
they like forcefully grab a tittie you
wanting it like suckle it [ __ ] attorney
grabbing their wives to you are they
going to someone else some other ladies
like what I'm assuming it's the wife
they don't specify but I'm assuming you
like women in their home if they're like
salivating because there's a there's a
new baby in the village and they're like
let's go get some tiny milk like that's
crazy
good yeah and sometimes there's cases
where the babies get fed formula so the
men can get the breast man what look
that's crazy my sister when she had a
baby she uh she over produced so much
milk she was like selling it like see
she would see would see would bag it up
and put it in a freezer and I see has so
much and the baby was like nah mom I'm
full he's like I want a shot Jack he's
like mom I want to help the family yeah
now I don't think she's doing it right
now because she just had mother she just
had my knees too and I'll she hasn't
told me about like any of my girl what
if that business grew and she's got to
keep doing that and there's women that
actually volunteered to donate their
milk for other babies that are in need
how long do women lactate for as long as
there's demand there's gonna be supplied
yeah what you mean so like as long as
something sucking on the boobs as long
as the milk is being extracted you will
forever produce milk because there is
demand so then if it stops yes for how
long does it take like to hear that like
sometimes women who haven't been
breastfeeding for a long time will still
have like a little like milk so why did
you start lactating right and then you
start using like breast pump and as long
as you keep pumping and pumping and
pumping that should go on for like yes
yeah so you like you like your son you
never had your nipples suck while you
green jacked off it's one of the best
things in the world I don't think it's
one of the best things in the world I
like it I got a pretty big areola so I'm
probably more sensitive to and they're
like big or they just like it's pretty
big bro that is a pretty big area
pepperoni it is it really is for being
Jack talk while eating sherbert ice
cream to that
I haven't had a sherbert ice crying
server-to-server sure I mean they're
different yes sorbet is way different
sorbets fancy I think it's like those
super neon colored ones I think I think
sorbet it's like just water and I say
sherbert siren screaming the people and
sorbets like very much sure birds the
pushpot thingy that is another sue this
is Sarah okay try that why you getting
jerked off you're gonna love it push
Bobby I don't know I can't like I get
jacked off or getting hit I have to
focus on that otherwise I will never
reset point I really can't just like
watch CNN I know I'm really funky like
I'm squeezing my ass shoes together
trying to force it out really yeah see
you may even enjoy I can't like I
haven't had good hey whereas this is
like oh but like is innocent is never a
short show this ain't a man named I just
never really been desensitized no I
don't think so I mean up because I enjoy
sex now I get why girls say they have to
take one for the team
yeah you you are literally stopping in
for the long haul with your boy yes you
ain't gonna just come in and beat the
arm of me I know guys that can come from
here like that I'm just not one of them
are you you gotta you gotta never I've
never got your back for you I've never
thought that like not not orally or like
like in the beginning of your sex life
its jacking off is 8 to 10 min the
process with you boy wow wow that's a
long time it is um what are you no
bigger than that
never let me know well Jack it off
because you said you have to focus so
I'm like are you like restart the video
oh I see that's why he has to open up
every single tab it have another
playlist because he has a [ __ ]
eight-minute jack incredibly stimulated
then huh
I do yeah and like you were sex like
sessions are usually between $25 or 15 I
just pumping multiple positions it's
still fun though because I know they
they enjoy it too
that's like women usually come two to
three times with sex with me no I'll get
one off I might have to change the
condom in their time but I'm usually
just woozy mean four five six
I wish but I'm right back like it make
my reach was like five five ten minutes
max and then I'm right back ready and I
can go the exact same time in between
five ten minutes max in here ready I
don't watch it that much like I have go
to clips but I will watch probably
videos or something I've been sent
before before I watch porn I like to be
the person in there I guess like in your
average week how much porn do you watch
I'm probably not even like ten minutes
worth I look at I look at my old videos
I'm gonna look at like that like it's
home video you will you record your sex
of paints oh yeah I feel like that's
that's an admission of guilt ooh that's
that's an admission of consent you watch
that more than your then porn yeah in a
week how much of that do you consume I
don't know I really keep count maybe six
seven days two hours worth of footage
man surprised you had an excel sheet of
how much you come a week I just do any
one minute like sometimes I have to rub
one out before I can get work started I
can wake up in the morning like I was
like I can't go to the gym like this
this is [ __ ] alone and horny yeah I have
to get this [ __ ] I bother get this evil
out of me so I can focus on this trap so
on a date night then I mean you gotta
get a chick bag early man got our 15
addy
I just hope Jane gotta be overly
[Music]